[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de france 24
dedicado al medio ambiente soy maría
clara calle por marina colorado hoy nos
concentraremos en la semana regional del
clima de américa latina y el caribe que
comenzó el 11 de mayo con república
dominicana como el anfitrión en el
evento virtual se reúnen gobiernos el
sector privado y líderes de la sociedad
civil
su propósito es prepararse para la
cumbre de la onu sobre cambio climático
que será en noviembre en glasgow la
discusión de la semana del clima en la
región se concentra en tres temas el
primero son las acciones que se pueden
hacer desde cada país para apoyar el
acuerdo de parís y plantear una
recuperación sostenible frente a los
impactos del cobi 19 la segunda temática
es la resiliencia ecológica en la que se
discuten los riesgos ambientales y qué
hacer para adaptarse el tercer y último
eje son las soluciones innovadoras para
debatir cómo américa latina' puede bajar
sus emisiones de dióxido de carbono y
contribuir a las acciones climáticas
aunque américa latina es la región que
produce menos gases de efecto
invernadero
allí las consecuencias del cambio
climático se sienten particularmente una
prueba de ello es que los huracanes las
inundaciones y las sequías son cada vez
más frecuentes y más intensos y los
desastres naturales son tan fuertes que
cada año 2 millones de latinos quedan en
la extrema pobreza a causa de ello es
por eso que diferentes organismos hacen
un llamado para que los compromisos
ambientales de cada país sean más
ambiciosos especialmente en 2021 un año
crucial porque es cuando las naciones
comunican sus contribuciones frente al
acuerdo de parís
al ritmo todas las naciones alcanzarán
menos del 1 por ciento de la reducción
de emisiones para 2030 en comparación
con los niveles de 2010 el ipc se
plantea que esa reducción sea del 45 por
ciento
entonces decir que los niveles actuales
son insuficientes es un eufemismo
el 2021 es el año en el que podemos
hacerlo y el año en el que nos acercamos
a la implementación del acuerdo de parís
y el año en el que por fin liberamos su
poder real y su potencial cuando el
mundo más lo necesita
y esa necesidad de compromisos las
sienten millones de latinos que se ven
afectados directamente por el cambio
climático por ejemplo en bolivia muchos
campesinos enfrentan una escasez de agua
generada por el derretimiento de los
glaciares de los artes y es que los
glaciares de la cordillera han perdido
casi un metro de espesor cada año desde
el año 2000 todo por el calentamiento
global la situación pone en riesgo la
seguridad alimentaria tal como lo cuenta
meriva acá en este informe
está
no sabe pronto seis manzanas duras en la
que de camino abajo no sabía abre ya
está x de 2 mil 500 manzanas
gervasio mamani es un agricultor de la
comunidad de capi situada a los pies de
la montaña antes cultivaba papas pero
ahora está orgulloso de sus manzanas la
variación es el resultado del aumento de
temperaturas que afecta al imán y cuyas
aguas escasean
el agua fría y no había ni demandar
aguanto los convivientes tranquilidad
hoy en día como ya el calentamiento el
imán se va quedando entonces estaba
guapa bajando poco a poco y las
comunidades de abajo y ya no tiene más
agua tampoco ya
las comunidades situadas a las faldas de
la montaña claman contra el cambio
climático pero no pueden hacer mucho
salvo adaptarse la experta en recursos
hídricos paola pacheco ha estudiado el
impacto del deshielo del imán y sus
efectos en capillas y bolivia más bien
es uno de los países que sufre de los
impactos del cambio climático en este
caso nuestros glaciares de todos los
andes' las poblaciones como capi y otras
poblaciones que dependen del agua de los
de los deshielos lo que pueden hacer lo
que lo único que les queda hacer es
adaptarse una adaptación difícil para
estos pueblos frente a una naturaleza
que ya no reconocen y de momento sin
ninguna propuesta política estas
consecuencias del cambio climático no
sólo se viven en bolivia y es que
américa latina es la región donde se
concentra la mayor deforestación y la
amazonía de brasil es uno de los puntos
más preocupantes el más reciente informe
del instituto impe muestra que la
deforestación en la selva amazónica
brasileña
aumentó el mes pasado pues se pasó de
406 kilómetros cuadrados deforestados en
abril de 2020 a 580 kilómetros cuadrados
en abril de 2021 es decir que hubo un
incremento del 42 8% y todavía no llega
la peor temporada tradicionalmente las
intensas lluvias de los primeros meses
del año dificultan que los madereros
salen a ese momento esto cambia entre
mayo y octubre cuando las talas y quemas
alcanzan su punto máximo en tiempos
secos
el gobierno brasileño respondió al
informe diciendo que no es apropiado
comparar meses individuales pero los
reportes anuales tampoco son
esperanzadores desde el 2015 la
deforestación en la amazonía de brasil
ha incrementado paulatinamente y se
disparó desde 2019 año en el que el
gobierno de yair bolsonaro comenzó hasta
alcanzar el récord de más de 11.000
hectáreas deforestadas en el año 2020
este panorama muestra uno de los tantos
problemas ambientales que enfrenta
américa latina y el caribe que se
discuten precisamente en la semana del
clima así llegamos al final de nuestra
emisión recuerden que pueden ver más
programas de medio ambiente en france24
punto com
[Música]